Razer is known for its many PC gaming
peripherals but they've also dipped into
the console space with a few products
one of which is the Razer rise you it's
a ps4 controller similar to the Xbox one
elite with its extra triggers and better
grips there is a catch though this
controller is currently only available
in Sony EMEA markets which means if
you're in the US you'll have to import
it it also carries a hefty price tag at
a hundred and fifty British pounds which
converts to about 195 US dollars however
the riser is actually a significant
upgrade from the standard Dual Shock 4
but before we get into what it has to
offer
be sure to subscribe to our channel and
check out our review of scuff gaming's
ps4 controllers now let's get into what
it has to offer and break down the pros
and cons of the Razr rise you the risers
body is bulkier than the DualShock floor
but this can be an up side it's suitable
for users who have bigger hands and want
more to hold onto the rise you itself
weighs about 10 ounces for reference the
DualShock 4 weighs 7 point 4 ounces this
controller only works through a wired
connection and there is no wireless
option it's USB port has notches around
it and it only fits the package of USB
cable a cable with low profile housing
can fit here but if you happen to
misplace the cable you'd be out of luck
the face buttons feel just like mouse
clicks while this takes some getting
used to the distinct tactile feedback in
short travel distance make X square
circle and triangle much more responsive
the extra bumpers on top and extra
triggers behind the controller also feel
similar to mouse clicks all four buttons
have a short throw and tactile feel and
using them as effortless they're easy to
program as well simply hold down the
left mouse button on the bottom row on
the front press the trigger or bumper
you want to map then the button you want
it to act as the controller will then
Rumble if you don't want the extra
triggers in the way for certain games
you can
move them with the package screwdriver
l1 and r1 have a satisfying click and
more surface area compared to the
DualShock 4 which makes them much easier
to use pulling l2 and r2 is smooth and
light on the fingers and much more
consistent than the DualShock port
triggers trigger stops also shorten the
throw and can slightly improve quickness
another highlight of the Rio is the
fluidity of the analog sticks going back
to the DualShock for the stiffness of
the sticks was more apparent and precise
movements were a little bit more
difficult rubber grips come attached to
the sticks which we recommend keeping on
since they prevented our thumbs from
slipping the same type of grip is also
wrapped around the controller's handles
the d-pad on the ratio is stiff and it
takes considerable amount of force to
press we wouldn't recommend using it in
games that heavily rely on the d-pad
like fighting games injustice 2 and
Street Fighter 5 come to mind speaking
of games how well did rise use features
translate to the heat of battle well
like our other reviews we played through
overwatch titanfall 2 blood-borne and
horizon zero dawn extensively titanfall
2 was a joy to play with responsive
programmable buttons stringing wall runs
together and hopping around and being
able to look freely all at the same time
provided a significant advantage landing
shots from afar was easier with the
fluid analog sticks having the option to
map character abilities to the extra
buttons in overwatch was extremely
helpful constantly jumping without
having to give up aiming by using the
extra triggers help to stay nimble
during firefights mapping the ultimate
button to another trigger was clutch for
offensive characters that require aiming
for the ability to be effective while
you wouldn't necessarily buy an
expensive controller for single-player
games the Rajah's advantages made
blood-borne and horizon zero dawn more
enjoyable mapping the dodge action in
both games to a trigger allowed us to
keep the camera moving while avoiding
enemy attacks
overall the rise you sets itself apart
from other premium controllers since the
extra buttons feel tactile and are easy
to press it's a pleasure to use with its
responsive buttons grippy textures and
fluid analog sticks as much as I enjoyed
using the razor rise you I can only
recommend it if you don't mind spending
a huge amount of money on a controller
or jumping through hoops to get it in
the US you'll also want to pass on it if
Wireless is a must if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to keep up with GameSpot don't forget to
check out my review of scuffed gaming
ps4 controllers and stay tuned for my
review of the Nikon revolution
controller
thanks for watching